the world's population has doubled in
just four decades 7.6 billion of us now
live on the planet and it's likely there
will be a billion more by 2030
but population growth varies from
continent to continent the fastest
population rises are in Africa and Asia
which will have eight of the ten most
populous countries by 2050 India is set
to overtake China as the country with
the largest population Nigeria has one
of the fastest growing populations in
the world it's set to become the world's
third most populous country in many
African countries women have on average
five children each in Nazaire it's seven
that's well above the global average of
2.4 children per woman populations are
also rising because they're aging fewer
people are dying than are being born in
the last century life expectancy has
almost doubled in some countries in
India it's almost tripled however in
some parts of the world populations are
decreasing Japan's population of 127
million is forecast to shrink by about
one third in the next 50 years but the
top ten countries with the fastest
shrinking populations are all in Eastern
Europe these countries suffer from the
combined effect of low birthrate a
relatively high mortality rate and
massive out migration as populations
shift the world as we know it will
change today's dominant developed
economies will be increasingly focused
on supporting the elderly whereas less
developed countries will be transformed
by population booms in 2100 it's
projected that one-third of all people
will live in Africa
a bigger population is a burden with
more people to house educate and feed
but it's also an opportunity a large
working age population can boost the
economy as long as there are enough jobs
and a strong infrastructure
you
you